how's go umbrellas many spirited pack
and welcome to a little bit different
video you bros requested that I show my
setup like a setup tour or whatever and
I really like watching setup tour so I
think he bros would enjoy it as well
main focus I don't like showing off or
whatever I think you bros know that from
me by now at least that I'm not like
that so I hope this doesn't get
misinterpreted but I also want you bros
to get a chance of getting some of these
things to ass racer and they are willing
to do a pretty awesome giveaway where
you can get some some of the stuff that
I use every day to make videos so this
is how it looks like when you aim better
it's a very very tiny room I don't know
if it seems like it but it is a tiny
room but it's also the first time I ever
have my own private space to make videos
I've been in six different locations
throughout the years while making videos
and they all been in like a living room
or like a basement or like just really
bad situations like I never even had a
proper desk until like two years of
making videos probably what you notice
first is these dual monitor setup this
is an ultra wide screen and it's amazing
to play video games on like the extra
peripheral vision that you get from it
is so cool if you slide this out you can
find my racer keyboard and my razor
mouth I actually prefer a mechanical
keyboard because it just feels better
but I couldn't fit it but this one is
really nice too and it doesn't make it
so much sound when I record like I don't
want you bros to hear a bunch of tapping
my play next we have my microphone which
is a blue microphone hahaha
it's called blue that it's red get it
huh it's probably not the ideal
microphone for me because it has a small
diaphragm and when I yell it makes the
audio click a lot easier but I think I'm
gonna sound so hipster I think it looks
pretty I'm not sitting on my butt
thing plugged in I promise down below I
have my razor blade it's a really
[ __ ] cool computer like if you don't
want to get a Mac and you want to play
games this is the slickest laptop ever I
think it looks so good and it runs
really well so I don't know what else
you would want down in this thing I keep
my PlayStation and it's my electric
light here's my guitar and here's my
sword in case the Nazis ever come back
at some painting that is really creepy
another creepy painting another creepy
painting I think art should be creepy or
melancholy I really that's how I prefer
it in here is where I keep my Mexicans
here's my couch this is where I sit if I
just play with the Marcia or some other
people or if I just play by myself which
rarely happens most of the stuff that I
ever play is for youtube up here we have
all my friends I don't have any friends
but they are my friends and they watch
over me when I record it's depressing I
get it and finally down below is my
desktop sometimes I add it for like 10
hours a day like it's crazy it's
important for me to have a good computer
so I save a lot of time we also have my
razor headphones the eraser for addition
I think is so I get a lot of question
how I record my videos and I use fraps
bandicam or a game capture device I
prefer a game capture devices because
they keep this file is pretty small I
edit my videos in Premiere Pro I'll show
you this is what a finished product kind
of looks like this is dark souls it's
funny cuz like people know so little
about editing videos and like a video
like this that takes 8 hour to edit I
upload and people complain that it's
short when I can really make like a
two-hour episode in so much less time
just because they're not edited I edit
all my thumbnails in Photoshop which I
usually do while the video is rendering
to me like 10 minutes to throw together
a thumbnail and I really enjoy doing
that like the way I actually got started
on YouTube was that I sold the artwork
that I made in Photoshop and just for
fun honestly but and they sold some of
them really well and I made enough money
to like actually buy a proper desktop so
I can finally start recording something
that's how it all started I guess all
right I'll have to end it there I hope
you enjoyed this tour I hope it doesn't
send the wrong message I hear a lot of
people who buy like an expensive
microphone and expensive camera and
setup and then they're like why am I not
famous there's so much wrong with that
but still it seems like a common
misconception that you have to have all
these things to get started on YouTube
or grow your channel I don't know maybe
times have changed but when I started I
had the microphone for my headset and
whatever webcam I could find so if
you're aspiring to make videos then
really with what's stopping you I hope I
can inspire other people with that even
though I have a better microphone AB
than before in a camera than before it's
still really the same setup as I had
since the beginning and I personally
think YouTube is not about being the
most professional or having the most
perfectly edited it's about the
entertainment of the video and having
fun with it and connecting with your
audience everyone is different of course
I can't say what's right and wrong but
that's how I see it at least but don't
don't go crazy shopping spree or
anything like that
that being said check out the link in
description and you can win some part of
this setup I think that's pretty awesome
I live like a video watching breaths and
I'll see you tomorrow
we're doing a new thing here we're gonna
charge it this looks even more broad
than before yeah bro
Frisco bro all right you ready bro bro
first